Maine has become the second state to
kick Donald Trump off the ballot in the
2024 primary it's not the Maine Supreme
Court it's not a group of robed lawyers
who are seriously considering the law
and bringing their legal scholarship to
bear it's just some democrat politician
whose name is shenna Bellow she's the
main Democrat Secretary of State she is
seen in photographs buddy buddy with Joe
Biden she visited the White House in
March she visited the White House in
June according to visitor logs she says
that the Electoral College that is to
say the way we do elections in America
is a a relic of white supremacy and
she's come out and single-handedly
kicked Donald Trump off the ballot which
is even worse than it sounds because
Donald Trump is not just the most
popular Republican candidate he is the
most popular presidential candidate in
the country